[Music]
a high forehead topped by disheveled
black hair a sickly pallor and a look of
deep intelligence and deeper exhaustion
in his dark sunken eyes Edgar Allan
Poe's image is not just instantly
recognizable it's perfectly suited to
his reputation from the prisoners
strapped under descending pendulum blade
to a raven who refuses to leave the
narrator's chamber Poe's macabre and
innovative stories of gothic horror have
left a x mark on literature but just
what is it that makes Edgar Allan Poe
one of the greatest American authors
after all horror was a popular genre of
the period with many practitioners yet
Poe's stood out thanks to his careful
attention to form and style as a
literary critic he identified two
cardinal rules - the short story form it
must be short enough to eat in one
sitting and every word was contribute to
its purpose by mastering these rules Poe
commands the reader's attention and
rewards them with an intense and
singular experience what Poe called the
unity of effect though often frightening
this effect goes far beyond fear Poe's
stories use violence and horror to
explore the paradoxes and mysteries of
love grief and guilt while resisting
simple interpretations or clear moral
messages and while they often hint at
supernatural elements the true darkness
they explore is the human mind and its
propensity for self-destruction in the
tell-tale heart the ghastly murder is
juxtaposed with The Killers tender
empathy towards the victim the
connection soon returns to haunt him the
title character of Liza returns from the
dead through the corpse of her husband's
second wife or at least the opium
addicted narrator thinks she does and
when the protagonist of William Wilson
violently confronts a man he believes
has been following him
he might just be staring at his own
image in a mirror through his pioneering
use of unreliable narrators poe turns
readers into active participants who
must decide when a storyteller might be
misinterpreting or even lying about the
events relating although he's best known
for his short horror stories Poe was
actually one of the most versatile and
experimental writers of the 19th century
he invented the detective story as we
know it with the murders in the Rue
Morgue followed by the mystery of Mackey
hojae and the purloined letter all three
featured the original armchair detective
C or ghost
Nouba who uses his genius and unusual
powers of observation and deduction to
solve crimes that baffle the police
poles who wrote satar's of social and
literary trends and hoaxes but in some
cases anticipated science fiction those
included an account of a balloon voyage
to the moon and a report of a dying
patient put into a hypnotic trance so he
could speak from the other side Poe even
wrote an adventure novel about a voyage
to the South Pole and a treatise on
astrophysics all while he worked as an
editor producing hundreds of pages of
book reviews and literary theory an
appreciation of Poe's career wouldn't be
complete without his poetry haunting and
hypnotic his best-known poems are songs
of grief or in his words mournful and
never-ending remembrance the Raven in
which the speaker projects his grief
onto a bird who merely repeats a single
sound made Poe famous but despite his
literary success Poe lived in poverty
throughout his career and his personal
life was often as dark as his writing he
was haunted by the loss of his mother
and his wife who both died of
tuberculosis at the age of 24 Poe
struggled with alcoholism and frequently
antagonized other popular writers much
of his fame came from posthumous and
very loose adaptations of his worth
and yet if he could have known how much
pleasure and inspiration his writing
would bring to generations of readers
and writers alike perhaps it may have
brought a smile to that famously
brooding visage check out this playlist
for more videos in our reading series
and let us know in the comments which
book you'd like to see us cover next
[Music]